from houston been good up for the very
funny rachel faith macmillan
rachel faith macmillan thank you for
coming on the show
have you uh been in austin very long
probably about 30 minutes oh that's
probably as much as you want to be in
austin
you're from houston
the better city it's
i wouldn't say it's better okay that's
good better i was okay it's better
um we have more of joe rogan's per
capita here though so here i hear
that here we go
uh we're gonna watch people date old
enron where i'm from right what enron
enron yes
famously went bankrupt corruption oil
banking
um yeah i love love a good enron
[ __ ] california they don't need power
that's right brown them out we don't
either
yeah we enroned ourselves during the
winter last year
well let's get a man and woman couple
just to warm things up we got a whole
man in here so if you're a man and you
want to date
the world's your oyster
but we're going to spin this around pick
someone at random and it's audrey scott
coming up as a woman
she identifies give it up for audrey
scott a woman
they get up for a cody a man
or so he said
can never be sure these days
well we would love for you to sign up we
can always sign up we need more people
uh find over two lgbtqia people do not
know each other or they're gonna go on a
date with each other
audrey scott is not here
there's two people in the bucket you got
it
audrey's got inside here so we're gonna
see a date with ray ray
he looks like a lesbian
is the other person also
uh
michelle s is that you
shall ask
well cody go take a seat watching some
women updates
take some notes buddy
we're going to watch ray ray and
michelle let's go on a date cody's
taking the walk of shame sorry buddy
um he'll be back later
but please sign up we got ray ray
the fans are blowing
ray ray and michelle s going on a date
for one minute then we interview you
and go
oh no prompts nothing nope just the
normal days
what's your name i'm ray ray
i'm michelle nice to meet you where are
you from what do you do i am from
florida okay
is it blues
is it hotter in florida no it's about
the same it's hell yeah in both places
are you from this area i'm originally
from san antonio but i moved here like a
couple years ago i was just in san
antonio two days ago very very pretty
yeah it's just like you're very pretty
oh thank you my goodness what do you do
i am a travel poker dealer and a [ __ ]
yeah that is uh so do you make a lot of
money doing that uh i can but i'm here
instead oh
i'm not sure
i make the right life choices yeah what
do you do i'm a nurse actually nurse
yeah nice do you get the
hello nurse all the time uh no never
actually remember yeah hello nurse
thank you usually it's more like hey
nurse
like i need something
right
i work in surgery it's the easiest job
nursing job i've ever had because
there's so many other people who take
care of the patient
like it's not just me and the patient
it's like a [ __ ] ton of other people so
i get to like not do a whole bunch it's
awesome cool i like that i like that
about you
and time give it up for ray ray and
michelle s thank you for going on a date
with each other
you said that surgery nursing is easy
that's always what i want to hear from
my surgery nurses that
this is easy
so what kind of surgeries do you
normally take part in um so in the past
i have done like i've been in
i've done minimally invasive spinal
procedures
i help patients get ready for surgery
and i discharge them when surgery is
over
okay
i love those minimally invasive spinal
surgeries
it's always such a minor deal to have
spinal surgery
yeah what a minimal
you're such a minimalist i love it
you're uh practical and efficient uh
you're a traveling poker dealer yep
wow
you went all in on this day you were
complimenting her and
really doing things that cody definitely
can't do between the first day
what book did you read
uh it was a pop-up book a pop-up book
yeah interesting so just compliment nice
just complimented did it work didn't
work out hi yeah they're getting married
i love you splattered
thank you this is like if twitter went
on a date with twitter
thank you for logging off to be here
tonight uh any any thoughts on this
beautiful couple in front of us i think
they're gonna make it so
the same shape classes that they just
yeah they're gonna hit right they're
both austinites her later it's gonna be
great
she's going to be dealing you cards
there's some pop-up books
and compliments that's going to be good
so you came with a friend tonight is
that a date or is that just a friend
date she's just my friend oh okay cool
queer women can be friends and not date
it's like really refreshing and unusual
but it does happen rarely
wow it's a unicorn
hard to find friends and hard to find
lesbians so the two of them coming
together very very rare
um
what uh
what library is your thing you look like
librarians uh
like you know right right right
everybody librarian i'd like to get a
book from y'all's library so if you just
let me know which library that is please
yeah
so um
what would be your first thing to do if
you guys wanted a date together
library from beyonce
you don't want to talk to her
dates that are some sort of like
activity rather than just like sitting
next to each other and trying to make
small talk you know like maybe way to
[ __ ] on the whole concept of this show
sitting around making small talk is what
we base ourselves on
like this is an activity
yeah it's a thing it's kind of different
from a normal day i heard
uh what's the weirdest date that you've
been on
this one
well hopefully uh you don't tell your
therapist about it it's uh really not
that traumatizing
uh is there are there any weird date
stories have you been dating in austin
a few years ago
this is like more than a few years ago
actually i went on a date with this lady
who was not really talking and
at one point she was like sorry i just
don't know what to say to somebody who's
22. and then the day like ended right
after that
what
that's the opposite of a pedophile
it was refreshing definitely like
pedophobic
uh that's weird you know just talk like
normal i think but
she couldn't she couldn't make it work
interesting were you attracted to her
uh like not as much as i could have been
not after that right
maybe she was deaf you know there's a
lot of big deaf community here in austin
is she making a lot of fun
signing to her and it gave her the
impression that you okay
so you went on this date and she didn't
talk to you
well did she not know that you were was
it through a dating app like shouldn't
she have known your age
yeah it wasn't through a dating app so
she did know my age so she was like i'm
gonna not talk on it see if i can get
this and that's it
and afterwards she texted me and she was
like by the way you have great legs no
like no
well now she's talking
now she's creep that's creepy
any weird dates that you've been on
um i went out with a guy one time and
his program oh gross
that's the worst
i kept asking him questions because his
profile was very bare uh you know it was
a tinder date obviously tinder date um
and he kept saying
how old do i look what do you think my
name is what do you think i did for work
and i was like
at first i was like going along with it
because you know i like a good mystery
but after a while i was like i am not
enjoying this and he goes playing guess
who with you
i was like i do not enjoy this he goes
no you do you really do enjoy this
that's the only thing he told you for
sure
like
maybe he was in witness protection
i feel like guessing is a lot of fun and
everybody else thinks it's like really
annoying so when you meet somebody who
likes wants you to guess everything it's
like it's a weird fetish for sure yeah
they just want to see what they look
like
how old do you think i am
no just kidding my name is
yeah 23.
22 still
still 22. you stayed the same age holy
[ __ ]
i'm 28 actually okay
got great skin
in a non-creepy way god you don't want
to guess
have you watched game of thrones yeah
you know melisandre with the necklace oh
yeah that's
necklace that's 745 years old
oh a real game of thrones character here
the uh
no
an elder lesbian teaching a younger
lesbian
the ways how long have you been in
austin
i'm only here for two weeks oh where are
you from oh florida
do a lot in two weeks yeah yeah okay
hell are you gonna show me later in
florida doing spinal tap surgery over
there it'll be great
florida the austin of uh the southeast
is uh it's miami at least does that make
it better or is just florida like yeah i
hear there's lots of good drugs in miami
i think as a nurse you probably got
better drugs
i'm actually curious what what do you do
what do they ask you you said that as a
nurse they ask you ques like just get me
things like drugs or that's all i can
think of
so there's like this joke that's like rn
does not stand for refreshments and
narcotics
but really that's what everybody's
asking me for all the time they're like
i want apple juice or i want pain
medicine or i want you to i want you to
help me like turn over in bed
yeah you people like that
goddamn cripples
refreshments in narcotics i love that
that's good that's awesome you know uh
you know how to change positions
what's your favorite
position like in in which sense
whatever the refreshments in the mirror
always
uh whatever position makes my patient
leave me the [ __ ] alone
[Music]
uh so
michelle s right
have you ever uh done any poker dealing
for any famous people yes oh
it's been a while but i used to deal the
world series of poker in the in the
summer
i'm actually what's up yeah what's up
what's up
that's also a great pickup line
um
so you know like david negrano and
that's
your table so i was actually on espn can
you imagine
whoa
the main one
that's awesome
so what's like the key to you gotta
throw it to them and make sure it
doesn't slide out of bounds or if you
get it off the table you lose
do you really get fired no
she's good with her hands ray-ray though
y'all are gonna be going to vegas soon
no we're going to vegas soon you and
your new date yeah
his own choice the florida of nevada
um
is there a lot of poker in miami i mean
a lot of cocaine and poker i bet
uh i combine the two i don't know what
anyone else does the fastest poker
dealer in florida
she'll take your hand away before you've
even seen it
that's how quick she is
uh so what uh what's the dating scene in
miami like uh it's pretty terrible
unless you're on cocaine
that's
the key
it's true for almost every dating scene
that's right
are there a lot of gay people there
there are but you just gotta like look
for them
they're hiding
it's not very liberal in most places
well i have no idea what that's like
[ __ ] we're in texas but
no that sounds uh awesome florida dating
you know a lot of sexy
bikinis
models
cocaine cocaine
yeah cocaine and poker but you just
gotta find the lesbians that's right
okay yeah
although the good thing is when you're
hitting on women they're just like hey
thanks they don't care
now now
i paid for these so we're good
then they give you the 20 and then they
walk away is that no
i'm not making a lot of money yeah [ __ ]
i'm doing it wrong 20th cocaine no
uh ray ray how was the dating scene in
austin
i feel like it's pretty good
you uh go out with a lot of texases
a lot of what tech excesses instead of
tech bros
at texas
experience that
uh well you haven't truly lived
well i feel like the woman that didn't
talk to you kind of sounds like a tech
tech person she's actually a professor
at the university of texas at san
antonio so
oh it's san antonio no wonder she was
such a loser
did you understand the cool austin ways
um that's cool so you uh what who do you
usually date in austin do you find like
dog walkers or
uh
i don't i don't think i have like a
specific type
you know i just kind of like whoever
also like let's be real if you're a
lesbian you don't get a lot of choices
she'll take anybody
he's got low standards he's feeling
special
no i'm sure you guys would have a great
relationship it seems like you guys
would do a lot of jigsaw puzzles
together you know
go
uh get little vests for your dog
together
uh do you guys have any pets
i have one cat
i like cats okay do you have any
no yeah i can't i travel too much to
have a a baby not a real lesbian then
revoke your lesbian
i gotta give the toaster back i guess
that's a toaster
that's in those buns i used to have a
travel job and i took my cab with me
everywhere it was great there's nothing
cats love more than traveling
one of those travel cats
what's your cat's name his name is
jasper he's black and white um
how old is jasper
uh
like four or five years old
i didn't get it when he was a kitten
uh an adoptee huh yeah i got an adult
cat
she's like this is a cut take but i
don't like to adopt puppies and kittens
i like to adopt cats and dogs
you don't want to teach them everything
you want a [ __ ] with some experience
something right
dog that can already shoot this to be my
preference that's good
so i mean uh how often do you travel i
mean you're a poker dealer you uh you go
all over the country the world uh the
country right now but just mainly
florida austin
i don't know why i specify the city but
vegas austin and miami where do you deal
in austin is there a casino here there's
a card room the lodge
okay poker room
it's like 20 minutes that north i don't
know which way north is sounds like the
domain
a lot of white people there
no it's like a mix there are a lot of
people
that's cool yeah i like to say that
all the scenes are good in austin you
can't find a scene that's like bad in
austin there's a scene for everything
here
yeah there's a bird scooter scene
there's a paddleboard scene
all the douchious activities have a
scene here libraries
librarian meetings
what uh what what uh what have you been
doing in austin so far
um not working apparently we've been
really slow or they over hired so i've
had a lot of free time
thank you for coming to the show
yeah thank god you're not working here
thanks for putting it on and of course
you know introducing me to my future
ex-wife yeah
i'll do the divorce reel better get
married quick because they're about to
take that away from us yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
why'd you that's a bummer i'm bumped now
um
yeah how do you
how vaccinated are you guys triple
boosted or does that come with the pink
hair they give you a booster in there
that's why my hair is pink
oh it's a side effect
fauci get on the
he's turning everyone into liberals with
the with the vaccine
i was uh how's that living in florida is
it uh weird with it's great i've never
met so many people that are like hey i'm
bragging about getting covered 17 times
you can say you got coven but you can't
say gay there
i say gay a lot yeah you should get it
all out before you have to go back
on the streets
yeah it's a compliment now
like yeah
uh
so what uh what what is like something
that people what don't know about
lesbians that you think that they'd be
surprised to know about them
um i think the really cool thing about
lesbians is that there is literally
every flavor of lesbian you could
possibly imagine
like like i'm a lesbian i'm a lesbian
now that's great like like there are
lesbians that are like really into
horses or disney or like there's like a
lot of goth lesbians or lesbians that
are like what kind of lesson that sounds
like a barbie doll i'm a horse lesbian
oh my god so i said
what uh what kind of lesbian would you
say you are a nurse lesbian
i'm the best time
oh yeah
how i met your mother or big bang theory
uh more like dungeons and dragons
oh [ __ ] that's extreme nerdy
are you are you a pretty big nerd
i could tell by that high five
that was a high five of someone who's
been on espn
a real athlete
um what uh what's the nerdiest thing
that you do on a regular basis
i'm trying to think about this
i watch a lot of tv
it's mainly sci-fi i listen to a lot of
podcasts
i'm a skater i put on like skates oh
like with the quads okay
it's nice
she'd be dancing you'd be like speed
skating leaving the dust
i was gonna say you're a poker dealer
you hang out with autistic dudes all day
that's pretty nerdy
i do they are youtube do you play
like how do you know this
have you seen them they're all a bunch
of nerds
they don't get into poker because
they're drowning in [ __ ]
they gotta put go all in on the poker
because they got nothing else going
no i'm sure your co-workers are great
you athletes
you asked if you played poker i play i
do play poker yeah
that was an insult that one kind of flew
over my head but yeah
i'm a poker player
poker face yeah i'm an e athlete
um but yeah uh thank you guys so much
for going on the first date of the show
and uh you guys will probably be coming
up again because you're the only people
that signed up
give it up for ray ray admission
michelle s
the first lesbian date that we've had
for a while
oh hey why don't you stay here and go on
a date with cody
tony
you're the only other person i find out
this has to take 50 minutes this day so
pace yourself
she's signing up
ray ray friend
welcome to and then another another
person signing up hopefully you're a
lesbian uh give it up for bringing them
all on give it up for cody and michelle
s going on a date with each other oh we
got so many people coming up
let's wait for them to sign up if
i kind of want to see this
i want to be cody and michelle s
um
okay
next up is this date and begin
well hello um you said you are you deal
poker at like you've been on espn
i think that's super cool because i i've
watched poker and been thoroughly
entertained by watching poker on tv so
it's kind of weird to think that i might
have watched you on tv and not known
it's been a long time though and i look
different oh i have no i don't remember
i don't think they show the no offense
oh no they showed me oh yeah because my
friend was texted me i was like hey
you're on tv and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
awesome you get like a dvd of that
showing like
i just like freeze-framed and took
pictures and i don't even know where
they are right now but do you play um
casually just with friends not any kind
of official capacity i don't want to
lose my money
you might not i might not but i'd be too
afraid that i would to to try are you
nervous i am yes you good with numbers
maybe don't try maybe yeah dear friend i
can have a good time with numbers but i
wouldn't say i'm good with numbers
what would you say you are good with
um
i'm good with bees apparently um i
didn't get stung today yes
end time give it up for cody and
michelle s
they went on a date with each other
cody is bad with numbers but good with
bees because that's the only grade he'll
get in math class is a b
fairly accurate yeah
so cody you're a beekeeper i am yes are
you uh you're just getting into the b
world
uh it's been like a year and a half my
mother's the like official beekeeper but
what i've learned by proxy she's like no
you should call yourself a beekeeper now
that's great because bees live with
their mothers too
it's queen
the queen yes uh i heard that you had to
kill a queen bee recently yes we did she
was just too aggressive laying very mean
babies very angry bees that would swarm
out and attack us like as we arrived in
the field before we'd even gotten to
their box
wow that's a post-birth abortion
kind of
michelle s just had a joke that she was
too afraid to tell on youtube
uh
what was it what was it she
i hate it when they're really aggressive
as you make your way to the box yes
yeah that would make sense
you got to be gentle i don't hate it
though
you got to beat that box up
find the queen bee and smother it
uh that's cool
what do you think about this bee hobby
of cody's i have to admit um i'm like
really afraid of bees
oh it's great once you put on the bee
suit you actually feel invincible so
when you do get stung every now and
again it's like oh shoot i got stung
what a surprise
do you have a picture
you see it anywhere in your yeah
probably i got a selfie of myself
wearing it with the bees in the
background awesome
is it is it a turn on if a guy says he
works with bees
i need to know this is that kind of like
poker
you're bad with number you're a nerd
that's bad with numbers that that bad
with numbers
i leave it all really at work i have to
do a lot of math work i don't like doing
math for fun with the bees oh no the
bees are a hobby oh
oh lord i don't know how your mom
it's okay you don't have to show a
picture
hard to transfer that onto youtube or
how many pictures do you have on there
i've got a lot i don't remember when i
took that picture of myself most of
these are my cat how sad is that oh he
has a cat two cats two cats michelle s
doesn't have a cat but cody does
you would have never guessed
cody um
i have two cats you uh you're like
you're like an honorary lesbian tonight
yeah thank you
well you have anything you want to say
to the lesbian community
i love you
i mean i'm not in a sexual way because i
can't but i love you
what a sweetheart
yeah this is why bees love him he's very
very nice well i'll show you the picture
later i don't want to spend it sort of
rhetorical it's good
yeah but yes bees are fun
um
bees are fun they are they get um angry
and aggressive when they are
[Music]
when it's gonna rain when it's too windy
when they just don't like you and
sometimes normally normal beekeepers
will replace their queens every two or
three years just for health reasons you
want a young healthy queen
um
they'll is that you're describing your
dating life right now
no you're looking for a queen yeah a
boss [ __ ] sure
uh well hopefully you don't kill her in
two to three years but uh cody is single
i am
uh
how old are you cody how old am i i'm
28. 28.
michelle s what's the what
28 year olds oh yeah two 28 year olds in
a row you're a magnet for another sunday
night people that live with their
parents
uh they are like
upperly mobile
so michelle s how many uh dudes have you
been on a date with
today
interesting today was
zero so far but just uh this one
uh
so you're bisexual
wha what uh what's up what's the worst
date you've been on with the dude what
it's like the craziest thing that's
happened just the one dude that didn't
want to answer my questions i think is
the craziest oh that's sort of like what
ray ray went through no that was me oh
that was you yeah she had the girl that
didn't talk to her yeah
hers was the person that kept saying
well what do you think i do oh the the
guesser yeah the guesser which is super
weird
like i'm trying to get to know you not
like 20 questions yeah he was just like
whatever i guess i'm like
all right you're rich you're right now
once out of me if you were my dream guy
you'd
tell me everything i want to hear right
yeah yeah like
you have money and you're a doctor no
just fill in the blanks yeah
is that uh
what do you think about that you think
that maybe uh you know
the dude was like sort of
freaking out or something why would
someone freak out i didn't have the pink
hair i was like
okay nice even if you did you'd mean
yeah right it's cute no excuse to freak
out and start making people guest [ __ ]
i like the pink hair it looks great
thank you
i i have to um confess something yes i
don't know my natural hair color
no
you're not really a troll doll
i would have gone with elf kim gosh
do elves not have pink hair
where are you controlled where do you
are
i went to d you got all kinds of hair
colors
so
what uh what made you get the pink hair
it's my favorite color i was trying to
come up with something easy and i have
like nothing i'm like that's just my
favorite color candy that's pink yeah i
want to eat my hair blue cotton candy
nobody right nobody yeah except for
straight dudes
i love blue
favorite colors
all dudes love blue
i think the last time i had cotton candy
was pink
see straight dudes like pink well cody
might not be the best example but
probably not i mean
you're not a straight dude i don't want
a [ __ ] i'm telling you like probably not
the best example of a straight dude if
you want
if you want some shining beacon of
masculinity it's probably not me
he's uh dangerous and provoked disaster
the queen bee
what do you think about this uh
beautiful couple rachel i think that
they're gonna thank you
you're so hopeful
whatever's gonna make it we're all gonna
have a big orgy afterward
yeah michelle do i get tickets for that
michelle
michelle s is gonna [ __ ] all of us
she's bisexual
i mean i needed another few of these
maybe
i am lonely i feel like i have so many
questions for you cody i just don't know
where to start like what happened like i
just
abs bees and
where did the
there's a lot i could tell i'm just
ruminating on this and thinking
who is your mom why why did she give
birth to a man that would do that but
you know
way back
i'm going back to the rabbit hole down
here but you seem like a nice guy you
know cody's a very nice guy yeah he
actually had sex and then he threw up
yeah honestly it's an old story on him
no i wasn't able to escape he was a
female it was all right
that's where we start yeah
intimacy issues and panic attacks and
what position were you in
uh
top missionary top mission yeah and then
i said i had to stop and then i
but i'll be back because i need to
finish [ __ ]
chivalry is not dead that's right
sorry no it's taking back i was on
bottom because i was lightheaded and it
took me a second to realize what was
going on and i said no you need to get
off
or whatever
how is that was the exes family she was
just a person i met that day and was
going way faster than i was expecting
and ready for better yeah i know
just all full of issues what was your
name
yeah i probably shouldn't say it because
of youtube
well you have to say her full name well
that's fair leah
like bill clinton's daughter or
something like here
that's a fairy tale remember her name
are you guys that's astoria
leah yeah okay
it's fairly ambiguous i guess i know
leah oh no
when did this happen
last year
latest i don't know august
july
sounds like a comet symptom sounds like
a code symptom for sure we gotta get the
nurse back up here
she's not working
she and michelle s is not dealing cards
everyone's relaxed cody's not dealing
with numbers
not if i don't have to
do you think you could date a beekeeper
michelle oh uh
maybe
do you think yeah all that sweet honey
you know what i mean
do you think you would get into
beekeeping for him no absolutely not
bee's terrifying me
i'm like a little scared
he was going to show the picture i'm
like yeah there's going to be a bee that
flies out of his clothes at any minute
and it's like oh it's like
candyman
gets to your point where you start to
wonder like how far away from my house
am i going or how far away from the b
field am i going to find bees because my
parents house are full of just dead bees
that have gotten tracked in on shoes and
whatnot and they get stuck in clothes
and
um
and it's just you know dead bugs get
cleaned up like everything else when
they get cleaned up but every now and
then oh there's just four bees here in
the garage and there shouldn't be bees
in the garage that is terrifying that's
like my nightmare
it'd be exciting i'd be like yeah i'm
going up for a day but i gotta go
through the bees first see my all the
meat fields are nowhere i don't know
thank you
like uh you do for work uh for work i am
uh actually an ecommerce specialist so i
do math all day long and respond or i'm
a team lead now i got a promotion
well you buy things on amazon no i just
returned them and it's not amazon but
it's similar you return things well i
return the money people don't want
things oh okay so you deal with numbers
crypto money all day fake money i mean
it's it really doesn't feel real because
it's all just digital numbers in a space
and like i could
mistype something and suddenly they've
overpaid us by fifty thousand dollars
and not to go back and fix it
like it'd be weird i hope you're good
with numbers so i hope you signed a
contract fixing my mistakes let's put it
that way like oh that's not right i
gotta fix that well at least you can
make it right before i sign off on it
did they let you wear the bandanna into
the
office wow this is pretty laid back
company yeah
they're cool guys it's a cool company
it's like etsy
no
keep guessing
i mean uh i'm sure you elon will give
you a job at twitter
no um because
he's trying to be progressive what's it
audrey audrey scott is here
we already called you
uh yeah i mean uh
we'll uh
you you'll come up next
yeah no problem
thanks for coming
did you
can you tell us about that i got i'm
still terrified
what was the joke that you told
six minutes of jokes well what was a
joke that you told oh my god this is
terrible it's not terrible wonderful
let's just say anything that comes to
your mind yeah um like look at cody and
just rail on him so i did stand up in
december for the first time ever i'm
still trying to get over it because it
was terrifying and i was like i don't
know if i like people watching me or
hearing me or laughing at me yes i like
people laughing at me
i just realized no i do you're a natural
you're meant for the stage thank you
um also now
start like freaking out about it so
you're doing great so i had a friend who
passed away and to honor his memory i i
did stand up because he did
he did somebody that he was somebody
that did stand up and inspired me
um so as soon as i started telling
everybody like i was doing stand-up
everyone just wants to tell you like
jokes right that's all they want to do
is like oh you're doing a stand up let
me tell you a joke yeah
so i was like all right tell me tell me
the joke right this does not make me
nervous at all just go ahead and tell me
he's like all right all right um
um
i'm like great great this is starting
great you're not even remembering the
joke how am i going to remember this one
right he's like um
somebody told me i was like toilet paper
and he did that i'm like great stark
like where's that
this is someone else telling a joke
this joke right and then he goes yeah
yeah he they said i'm like toilet paper
i'm like come on kid i don't really have
all day like just tell me the [ __ ]
joke like you're setting this up is it
like the aristocrats like no and then he
finally goes
it's because i'm on a roll
and i said
it's like toilet paper that's the
whitest joke i've heard
my nephew is really funny sometimes for
11.
he's on a roll i have a joke about
toilet paper but it's not really a joke
that was very long
uh
it's interesting
like toilet paper
um but yeah i mean uh that's something
that you said on stage
okay
on stage you told someone else calling a
joke
just uh just be like toilet paper i'm on
a roll you know just keep it short the
idea is that he's my nephew and he told
the joke shitty and i just railed on him
because he's that's a good thing to say
it was a shitty toilet paper just a
shitty joke
i wiped my ass and then sorry buddy you
have any hilarious jokes that are under
30 seconds long
no not that are under 30 seconds all my
jokes are shaggy dog stories that take
forever and then you grow up
you look like you belong in scooby-doo
yeah speaking of shaggy dogs
what uh mystery do you guys think you'd
solve together
oh wait no i do have one joke what do
you call a pair of banana peels yeah
what do you call two banana peels
how do you wake up lady gaga in the
morning
how
poker face
with cody's penis
that one kills on the poker tables guys
that's also uh how you get accused of a
sex crime
yeah um so you guys uh do you guys think
you'd uh go on a second date
i mean it depends on what the context is
like i'd go on a trend date like i think
there's a green tavern like gaming bar
for nerds i'd go to that with you and
hang out
but then you might have to do math and
you hate numbers
you'd have to work
out of
when you're not uh whatever the numbers
lighter can
nerds we get along really easily because
they're just not hateful people
not normally
so uh yeah i mean uh thanks for going on
a date and uh hope to see you guys up
here soon yeah you know maybe
you guys will have to come up because
there's like a lesbian or like your girl
cody
there's a straight woman or something
but give it up for michelle s and cody
yeah
thank you guys for going on the date
let's uh pick up another couple oh we
got uh audrey coming up so we don't have
to pick a woman
and for a van we got josh
josh going on a date with audrey scott
there she comes
audrey welcome to the show
did you go sign up at sanjac yeah
did you what's what's watch again
anyways here's josh and audrey scott
hello give it up for them hi josh
how are you audrey i'm all right how are
you doing well yeah what'd you do today
i slept in i took my dog to the park to
find sleeping in
12 noon
it's like 4 p.m
what did you do today
uh
i drove back from san marcos and i went
to a farmer's market and i worked out
school what'd you get the farmer's
market pierogies pierogies yeah i got
meat and then uh
cheese and potato ones too
i like the cheese and potato better
sometimes i'm pretty lazy though i work
at a restaurant so i just eat their food
yeah yeah what do you do i sell security
software to companies oh you rich
what kind of car do you drive a ford
ranger oh you're rich
ranger what's the mileage on that uh 150
000. all right okay how long you had it
five years do you change your own oil i
do nice
i hate a guy who doesn't change his own
oil you lazy stupid [ __ ] like
you're literally paying 40 bucks at
jiffy lube to wait three hours like
don't like it you know what are you
driving
nissan altima okay
yeah on oil too yeah
end time give it up for these oil
changers
they're over here swapping drip pans
uh this is this is what happens when old
austin meets new austin we got the tech
bro meeting uh cesar chavez street over
here
what uh what brought you over here from
riverside audrey i don't live there i'm
not from there that's not funny
okay
very serious
got a tattoo of a fist you don't want to
mess with her
um
josh do you have any strong political
beliefs
uh no i mean i i'm against the insanity
that's going on right now what's
insanity uh you know the supreme court
leak and what texas what do you oh you
like babies or do you hate them
i i like babies yeah babies are cool oh
but babies but uh but i think you know
you have babies this guy always wraps up
uh you just made them pay on themselves
yeah i've never i've never been party to
an abortion no he's not a feminist
skye [ __ ] i'm not paying to kill
babies [ __ ] up
i just never had to
nice
never had to kill a baby shooting blanks
that's called white privilege
it's on the bucket list
why
why not
man white people say the craziest [ __ ]
do you like alex jones
oh
all right
you might be too straight edge for
audrey she's a little extreme what's the
most extreme thing you've done what's
the most hardcore thing the most
hardcore thing that you've done besides
put that shirt on today
cliff jumping
whoa hey that's badass
where is
whoa
he said it like don't you know hopefully
the island that's a part of the united
states like the big island
nice
nice
did you uh land in water did you have a
parachute
oh okay how high up were you like 80
feet that's pretty cool were you scared
i was very scared did you do it multiple
times i did it twice nice to go with
my family actually
my parents and my brother and sister
you have a brother and a sister
are you middle uh older or what i'm the
oldest oh you're the oldest how old are
you uh 36. oh nice
i'm also 36. we have so much in common
audrey is going in for the kill after
she found out he's rich
that ford ranger though
she's got four correction money
are you a pretty handy man around the
house you uh you can fix things yeah i
come from a family of carpenters oh nice
jesus was a carpenter are you oh
everyone on this stage is getting wet
right now oh my gosh
it's just swamp ass you know
josh i think i'm attracted to yours
i do have my own house yeah that's
incredible we're at
south austin down by uh mckinney falls
what's your address that's too much
information good health is your social
do you have health insurance uh yes do
you have a life insurance policy no when
was the declaration of independence
written
1776 thank you
wait for audrey
cody stop clapping
so josh you uh you're a homeowner you're
you're an oil changer you're
you're a man about town are you here on
a date by chance i am here on a date oh
no
what you better change your oil you know
right now i won't steal him he's too old
for me
yeah he's too accomplished and handsome
and homeowner more like homo nerd
where's your date
uh she's like honey i don't you're
beautiful you are beautiful what are you
doing where are you why did you let him
come up here
she wrote my name down and put it in
there man
nice
okay see y'all's birthday michelle s is
over here it's your first date oh my god
you're so supportive i like that the
threesome on the first date
you're gonna be his first abortion
poor what do you want you want like
yeah but what kind like what's the ratio
no i asked you a question
you just said yes
all right she's a yes woman did you guys
have did you guys have dinner before or
are you taking her no we just met him
josh is going to end up with more
white spots on his shirt after tonight
okay y'all met on a dating app didn't
you oh we might have yeah which one
christian mingle venmo farmers only
know which one
which one yes hinge facebook jiffy
bumble
your mom yeah you look like a bumble or
hinge guy we got cody right here with
the beekeeper he's more of a tender guy
right there he's like always bumbling
around on bumble trying to look for
queens
he's gonna kill in two years yo you good
women get too much privilege on bumble
yeah it's about time that they suffer
more
that's what the supreme court was all
about it's all about keeping those
[ __ ] on bubble humble all 98 pages of
that [ __ ] it's the first thing you've
ever read no it's not okay
what
what would you say your aesthetic is are
you like grunge are you uh hip-hop are
you emo questionable i don't know i'm
just like questionably gay all the time
people always think i'm a lesbian no
matter what i'm wearing whether it's a
dress whether it's shorts whether it's
pants
i always come off lesbian
michelle s
is it do you uh is this is this what a
lesbian do you think she looks like a
lesbian do you have the does she have
the lesbian seal of approval
is emma stone a lesbian oh the lesbians
think you're a lesbian jew i've been
getting this since i was 14 and i've
never been a lesbian you're 16 now
[ __ ]
you're not supposed to be drinking that
beard
well maybe what driver's life
if you don't want people to think you're
a lesbian stop asking people about oil
do you change your own
oh [ __ ]
i just care about that stuff i think
it's important to be independent and
she just she wants to take the money out
of big oil yeah i hate big oil
lube and all that yeah uh josh what uh
what do you think about uh audrey's uh
you know very very uh extreme uh outlook
on life and she's kind of got a lot of
energy
is that what you're is that are you
excited about that i don't think you
like me
i think uh no i like i like a you know
confident independent woman you you
wouldn't date me though i would i would
take you on a date and see what oh yeah
well i can't guarantee spend your money
i'll buy two bottles of wine
play around
i'll get some steak like i don't i don't
mind a nice steak
all right how do you like your steak uh
medium rare okay sam we have one thing
in common
and the oil two things in common
i feel like uh you take audrey on a date
if you want to be put in a headlock
she does kind of look like ronda rousey
thank you so much
look how happy she is
she's so happy to be called fierce and
uh scary and
yeah all that what uh what do you think
i look like you think that uh
asian
the korean zombie that's hilarious
you look asian too audrey i know
i'm not
you can't use that sound on me
let's do it again for you
josh have you ever dated a girl who's
not white as [ __ ] yeah absolutely nice
asian or black yeah my high school
girlfriend was korean nice thank you for
dating us
south or north it counts it happened in
my life okay
when you were a child you dated an asian
no no no no
yes how did it go
how much
that's awesome what does your dad do
he's a carpenter oh yeah he flips houses
nice hmm damn he's wrong
small cluster tiny house
yeah
he's a prankster he's like in frat he's
going around flipping houses he's just a
real estate agent
i guess yeah no
he's got that hawaii money
yeah he doesn't who paid for hawaii did
you take them out uh we all paid oh nice
together how long were you out there for
just a week
just a week that's a long time to be in
hawaii that's really cool
that was fun
nice
you uh didn't get a tan um no look at me
i don't i don't tan
how long have you been in austin uh five
years
wow from
delaware nice from virginia that's cool
beast coast first uh first show i saw
was uh beach boys on virginia beach
really i went to the college in virginia
beach school yeah
where did you learn to change your own
oil
uh my dad
nice
dad
he's a good dad he sounds like a great
father
do you like steve yeah what's that do
you like your mom yeah i love my mom
what does she do
uh she's a nurse she's a chief nursing
officer of a hospital
she's a smart lady yeah my mom uses
special ed kids and learns more from him
than
anyone else
does she provide a lot of refreshments
and narcotics yeah that's uh
he got her doctorate in a christian
refreshments narcotics
yes she's got that capri sun [ __ ] i
could see that
audrey's mother-in-law
god
so what do you usually look for on a
date josh
uh
we'll see
i guess i guess someone that's uh deep
into something more serious you know not
someone that just wants the first date
no i mean not you know just yeah the
possibility the possibility
is he's the man trying to be loved i get
it
you want a family i'm 36 the fuckboy
days are behind me okay
well wearing that shirt then
shirt doesn't say that false advertising
josh
have you you've always had that jawline
you know i'm sure you've done very well
for yourself um you look like you work
out
mm-hmm occasionally occasionally lies
are you looking for children to not
abort you're working
to carry the term possibly yes okay
possibly
he's got a home he wants to put a baby
in it do you want twins
sure sure i'm not here
yes man yo could if someone had twins
could you abort just one of them
i know the answer to that is yes
you know that
i love when the other twin just eats the
other one
that's called murder
should we charge that kid with murder
as soon as it pops out you're under
arrest throw it on the ground
mom is weird for you huh
yeah
a lot of things have been weird for me
what's the weirdest thing that's been
weird for you
what weird
i don't
one time i uh invited a guy over that i
met on tinder when i was 18 in college
and he was getting kicked out of the
navy for smoke and weed and he's also
ex-mormon i'm an ex-mormon and i invited
him over to do mushrooms before he moved
back to oregon
and i've never done mushrooms with a
stranger so i get him in my dorm and
there's a poster on my wall that says
imagine we're four hours into the trip
he's walking around my room i'm laying
in bed vibing and
i look into his eyes he goes imagine
imagine and he whips out his dick
and he pees everywhere oh
that's not even sexual at all actually
it was horrifying because i'm like peak
tripping and then so this big-ass guy
from downstairs like grabbed him by the
head put him in an uber and the uber
driver is calling like he's only saying
the word imagine i don't know where to
put it oh you can drop him off to the
police station the hospital get him the
[ __ ] away from me so they bring him back
to the naval base and he runs away from
the gate officers he breaks his hand on
a light pole audrey you talk to him
after this
i hit him up so this happened when i was
18 i hit him up a year ago i'm like hey
how's it going lucas and he never
responded so i guess i dramatized him
for life
it's his fault he broke his hand on a
light pole then what happened and then
he got arrested by the uh the officers
and in my weed my grinder went his
piss-covered backpack that he took with
him so he got in trouble for that too
the uber ended up
costing 250 because he peed all over the
car
and then his roommate gave you the money
for the uber and then asked me out and
i'm like no
absolutely not
and that's it
you know actually uh
whipping your dick out of peeing
everywhere is how mormons have sex
that's not true i'm mormon
how do you know
well because they don't they do it
through the sheet or something they're
weird about it talks about this [ __ ]
it's never a mormon that talks about it
no one ever stokes
no one ever does the [ __ ] you talk they
just [ __ ] and they lie about it like
that's
like everyone else
you hit him up and you wonder why he
didn't he was like nope
yeah
that was that was pretty weird that
happened uh yeah so you you've seen a
lot of weird things yeah
yeah i've never done mushrooms with a
stranger again
would you do mushrooms with josh
no
what do you think josh would do he's a
stranger i don't [ __ ]
i don't know you well enough i don't
know what you i don't know what your
brain would do you know some people are
just like eat myself and i'm like ew
don't talk about that
he might whip his dick out and pee
everywhere hey
we're hoping that's fair though you do
need to know that the people you're
tripping right you need to know the
mental side i used to sell that [ __ ] and
then like if they weren't a stable
person i wouldn't give it to them i'm
like you don't need this like you need
to see a therapist first um
all my best drug dealers were mormons so
that makes sense
yeah no that's a weird uh character arc
you went from
you you bought weed from your parents
just anything really oh that's cool
why you're so badass
i'm we're up here with a couple badass
chicks josh you feel uh threatened or no
i think it's great yeah i feel like i
can really shine here as a man have you
been married before josh no never
married no kids why
uh what's the secret what are you doing
wrong
that's that's what i'm trying to figure
out because you just yeah what is he
doing wrong is he [ __ ] up yet violent
what are you saying
oh she's confident
i like you just before you marry him
y'all should get married tonight no
balls you won't
sounds like you're getting delayed buddy
no yeah
i like that damn no one cares about them
get nobody all right
yeah it's fine you don't have to care
about these lovers
god
what uh what are you gonna do after this
uh this show
uh probably grab a drink somewhere
nearby nice
are you gonna drink it too or just grab
it are you gonna take grab it and hold
it you know
yeah
you're gonna take your date yeah yes
okay
hopefully he's looking for comfort like
i'm gonna go grab it
great that's good you're gonna bring
audrey with you or don't yeah don't
bring me i've got plans i'm sorry josh
you